Okay, danke schön Herr Schmidt. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin fünf und ich bin eine Frau.
Ah, sorry. Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren 1970, am dritten Mai.
Wie viele wiegen Sie? Wie viele Spiege?
Ja. Ungefähr 55 Kilogramm.
Wie viele sind Sie?
Ca. 1,68 m.
Okay, Frau Maga. Maga, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt und bin geboren am zweiten, sechsten, 61.
61.
Okay, Frau Maga, wissen Sie Ihr aktuellen Gewicht?
Ja, ja, 78 kg wiege ich.
78 kg. Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
1,67 m.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin geboren 14.08.1979.
Ja, 14 oder 40, ich konnte Sie nicht gut verstehen.
14.08.1979, ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
46 Jahre alt, okay, okay, danke schön.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 1,65 m groß und ich wege ungefähr 70 Kilogramm.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausärztin oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt heißt Herr Dr. Schmidt.
Herr Dr. Schmidt.
W-I-R.
B, Wieberta?
B, okay.
Frau Röber.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45.
45, okay.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 1.07.80.
Alles klar.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie und wie können Sie es zurzeit, Frau Röber?
Ich bin 1,65 m und wiege 69 Kilogramm.
69.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 39 Jahre alt.
39, wie wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 17.09.85.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Wieberta?
Ich bin 1,84 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
89 Kilogramm.
Aber wenn Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, also ich darf keine Nüsse essen
und ich habe auch gegen Krässe, also dieses grüne Grau, da habe ich auch
eine heftige Allergie, also da habe ich mal richtig Atemnotanfälle bekommen.
Wie ursäen sich die Allergien und Gras?
Also diese Nüsse, da kriege ich total rote Flecken im Gesicht
und das Juckt, also und Gras.
Diese Krässe, die Krässe, da habe ich eben so Atemnot bekommen.
Was mache ich jetzt mit einem großen Bogen drum herum?
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt, ob ein Hausarzt?
Ja, das ist Dr. Sieger.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 65 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
1. April 1964.
Wie groß sind Sie?
lange nicht mehr gemessen vor Dr. ungefähr 1,75 Mal.
Wie schwer sind Sie so weit?
Ich habe immer gleich gewählt, ungefähr 70 Kilogramm.
Okay, und wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hauptärztin?
Herr Dr. Müller, der hat mich hier überwiesen.
Okay, danke für den Einfragen.
Frau Schell, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann wurden Sie geboren?
Das ist der 10. Mai 1966.
Und darf ich fragen, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
1.168, glaube ich mich vertragen.
Kein Schülung.
1.168, nicht 1.66.
Okay, und wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,68 m und wiege momentan 55 Kilogramm.
55 Kilogramm?
Ja.
Okay, bei Belastung.
So, haben Sie auch Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich heiß bin.
Also, haben Sie eine Schmerz?
Schmerzen habe ich nicht. Nein, keine Schmerzen.
Keine Schmerzen.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin schon 76.
26.
Wie lange sind Sie geboren?
Am 25. April 49.
25. April 49.
49.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1.178, war ich jedenfalls einmal, vielleicht bin ich schon ein bisschen kleiner.
Und ich wiege 89 Kilo noch.
Okay, alles klar.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Sacken?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 10. Mai 1994.
490.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Sacken?
1,80 m.
Wie viele wiegen Sie?
Wie viele geht nicht? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Sacken?
Ich wiege 100 Kilo.
100 Kilo.
Und was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Notfallsanitäter.
Okay, in diesem Fall, wir sind Kollegen, das heißt ja.
Sind Sie Notfallsanitäter?
Wir sind Arzt.
Ich bin Arzt, aber wir arbeiten in den Gesundheitsbereich.
Deswegen habe ich das gesagt.
Danke, ja, das stimmt.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wie heißt Ihre Hausärztin oder Hausarzt?
Ich habe keinen Hausarzt.
Das ist ein wichtiges Stress schon.
Könnten Sie sobald eine Anmendung an Hausarzt machen?
Nein, das geht nicht.
Ha-ha-A-doppel-N-A.
Okay, Frau Müller.
Müller, bitte.
U-U-Umlaut, nicht U-U-U-Umlaut.
Müller.
Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42.
42.
Und wann wurden Sie genau geboren?
83. 83. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,69. 1,69. Und wie viel wiegen Sie? Ja, ich
wie viel wiegen Sie? Ich bin 28 kg. Können Sie wiederholen? Frau Lawrence, wie hat Sie
Sie und wann genau Sie geboren? Ich bin 22 Jahre alt und bin am 14. August 2000 und 2 geboren.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Lawrence? Ich bin 1,65 und habe circa 73 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie, bitte? Ich bin 62. Am 18. Mai 63. Und welcher Tag? Am 18. Mai. 18.
Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,63. Wie viel wiegen Sie? 80 kg.